The Joe Rogan experience,
but I was always living in Dallas in and I was 42 years old when ecstasy hit the
streets Mbma and uh,
I,
I'd never taken any drugs.
I didn't even smoke pot.
Came out of the navy and everything.
And that's the Oregon attorney right in,
in Houston House and attorney.
Then in Dallas I started a computer company.
I had a personal computer company that while in 1981 we outgrows Microsoft,
you know,
I had four color picture in Forbes magazine,
made the front page of the Wall Street Journal and really then ibm came in and
crushed us like a bug.
Wow.
What was the name of your computer company ready for?
This is in Dallas,
Texas named it Dynasty Dynasty Computer Corporation.
But hilarious.
It was a,
we were the amway of computers.
I had like 3000 distributors around the country and uh,
it was,
it was crazy.
And we sold.
We sold this machine.
You want to hear this anymore?
Yeah.
It was an eight k machine with 16 K of Ram and it was a 12 inch black and white
monitor and a cassette tape deck is what we use for input and output and you'd
have to load your,
your,
uh,
your boot program and then you'd get a crc error.
So you're just the tone and rewind it and then loaded again.
And,
and we sold hundreds of these for 3000 bucks each.
Why?
And parents would say,
you know,
why do I need this,
you've got recipe program and,
and Pong and a couple of games.
And I said,
I don't know how you need it,
but if your kids don't have this,
they're going to be left behind.
Why?
When they're 30 years old.
And uh,
later,
uh,
I was talking at one of the job of conventions in San Francisco and a guy came
up to me and gave me his card and he's CEO of a company like 100 programmers and
all.
And he said,
you don't remember me,
do you?
And I said,
no.
He says,
my dad bought a computer from you.
And you told them that would help me.
Wow.
So I don't know if anybody else got help.
At least one customer turned out with.
What year was this?
Uh,
let's see.
We went out of business.
I started in 79,
79 and we made it to lady for while.
And it was,
it was great.
It was,
you know,
you heard of the DOTCOM bubble.
Well this was the PC bubble.
It was before ibm got in and,
you know,
we'd run short and memory chips and I'd call up my friend had osborne and he'd
shoot me some and then when I got some back I had shipped him and it was a
closed network is pretty good old boy thing,
you know,
fascinating.
And there's a lot of fun.
It was great fun.
But uh,
we didn't know what we're doing,
you know,
we're geeks and,
and uh,
I didn't know anything about cash flow or business,
you know,
I've been an electrical engineer and a lawyer,
but I didn't know anything about business.
And so we,
we just sort of sold ourselves out of business.
And by the time we were done the last six or eight,
nine months,
I was a financing the thing by selling ecstasy,
ecstasy come into play.
I was a,
I was doing this computer thing and,
and a close friend of mine,
a lawyer in Biloxi,
he called me one day and he says,
what do you know about ecstasy?
And I said,
what do you mean?
He said,
well,
it's a drug.
And I said,
well,
I don't do drugs.
He says,
it's legal now.
This isn't Texas.
And at that time you're getting 30 years life for a single joint.
And so there's no way I'd touched something like that,
you know,
and I get join for one joint.
And so he said,
no,
this is legal.
And I had a friend,
a friend of my wife's,
actually,
she was a model in town,
ran with the fast crowd and I met with her and she fixed me up.
And uh,
so I got involved in and then my friend wanted some.
I sent him 50 and I started telling friends about it and I became really
evangelical about it.
And pretty soon I'm buying hundreds and 500,
600 and,
and uh,
I didn't realize it at the time.
The Guy I was buying from was actually the main man.
And uh,
the big guy that started the ecstasy hit the street in Dallas,
had been out here in west coast for several years with the therapist and all but
Dallas and the stork club was the ground zero.
And the stork club was just stark.
Club was so big.
Madonna moved to Dallas to be close to that club.
Why?
There's a documentary going to be coming out soon,
called the stark project.
And uh,
it was an insane place.
It's really the,
the genesis of house music before,
or even Chicago is called Stark club music.
And then it in and there were bowls of ecstasy on the bar where you go by,
you know,
giving 20 bucks and get a,
get a hit because it was all legal and uh,
you know,
they had chill space.
It was a crazy place that you,
it was like burning man in a building.
In fact,
Larry Hagman was a regular there.
And,
and,
uh,
in,
in this movie that's coming out,
he's quoted as saying he lights up and he said,
oh,
it was the greatest party on earth.
He says,
the only better party is burning man,
but that's like putting the stork club in the middle of a desert.
But some people would get all dressed up burning man type and we're talking name
brand people,
you know,
the talking heads and people like that.
And Madonna even w showed up,
George W dot ben there.
And uh,
it was just wild and crazy and they played this house music and they had a chill
space and coed bathrooms.
It's just a wild place.
And uh,
that's,
that's really where ecstasy started spreading.
Now I was selling to all of my friends and,
and a lot of coworkers and everybody.
And we were really serious about it that I would make people read all whatever
literature there was,
you know,
there wasn't very much.
So there's a speech.
Sasha gave a talk that Rick Doblin had given up the international,
a health organization,
but not much.
But we were really serious and I was sort of not in the club scene.
I was getting people together in small groups and doing it.
But I sold a lot of ex and I was getting deep discounts and so I was using that
money to cash flow of my business.